hello everyone well
come to the presentation thing sir
thanks for coming and thanks for
attention
yeah today actually we're gonna talk
about the kind of we proposed the kind
of an application and we call it as a
trash assistant and with with my
colleague Christian and we are working
for PwC and we are located in Gdansk we
are in actually financial crime unit but
it's SUV understand is not related with
financial crime or anti money laundering
maybe auntie something else but actually
we kind of came up with this idea and
our let's say management team where we
supported this we somehow wanted to
promote it as a social responsibility
project so we are also planning to knock
on the door of the Gdansk Miss polity
because they seem they're interested in
kind of application and make it like
wider and so on of course today we would
like to mention you what we did how we
collect the data and what kind of
approach did we use and then there's
gonna be small demo version but don't
expect so much please because this is
very very prototype even like very early
alpha version of the app so but we are
on the progress of improving it and then
packing it and put it into two store
Play Store and App Store soon well this
is our content for today first of all we
would like to mention what is our
motivation behind this of course i
shortly gave you kind of an information
but i would like to tell more and then
we use transfer learning for this task
which is quite popular nowadays and it
actually saves a lot of time and it
helps data scientists so we will talk
about it a little bit and then we had
two approaches when it comes to
classification tasks because at the end
okay we have image recognition task but
actually basically we are
trying to classify those images right
and then we will talk about the key way
up so have you ever tried to build any
Kiwi up Kiwi okay how many people heard
about the Kiwi okay cool
and actually this is very interesting
framework we're also going to talk about
it it allows you to build cross-platform
applications using Python but I would
like to tell you that we are not an
expert on cube we just discovered it and
we just wanted to use bytes and to build
such you know application basically it's
very interesting and because previously
we were using shiny and we were looking
for shiny application we were looking
for some alternative to this because
we're data scientists unfortunately not
developers so we don't have so much
knowledge about the proper software
development basically so anyway we
decided to go with Kiwi and we'll see
what we actually tried to do yep
as you may know in all over the Europe
and the this European Union was very
strict about this trash segregation and
even they started to rank countries so
and they set very hard rules and they
even was going to find some countries
because of not very well structured
trash segregation system or you know
system or approach so in gdansk we
living in asked as we mentioned and the
mini spot is also very strict and
they're very aggressive when it comes to
trash segregation so even one of the
companies was fine we know it so you
cannot tell the name of the company but
the fine wasn't you know like a small
amount and also they are even giving
rewards and you know tax deduction based
on their trash segregation performances
to companies to buildings and so on so
basically we decided to maybe provide an
application because sometimes it might
be confusing when you try to just throw
your trash you're going in front of the
bins and you're
looking at the trash looking get the
beans and you're saying okay what now so
let's talk about the milk box right so
what do you think where you should throw
the milk box to to pay proof okay cool
okay so it was confusing for us you know
it that's good English we are confused
but were so you know it's capital so
probably you know we're next to the sea
well anyway so yeah it was a bit
confusing for us and then we just
decided to have a nap of an application
to provide the solution for this
basically the application main idea
behind the application like this okay
you will go in front of the trash room
with a lot of question marks on your
mind and then you will just take a photo
of your trash and it will tell you the
which is the class of this trash and you
would know which bin you should throw
and then we of course didn't have so
much time to you know collect trashes
and also you know it's not a nice work
to go and take a photo of trash and so
on and we found open source data set for
this and we use transfer learning we
decided to go with widget is 16 and we
basically customize this architecture
frozen frozen some layers and you know
provided some customized layers and the
results are quite promising and
afterwards we implemented this we did
you 16 customize we did you 16 model to
achieve it up so then basically it was
very promising
as you can see in gdansk this is the
mascot of the trash segregation even
those instructions instructions are in
English so even you know they think
about the foreigners this is very nice
so basically there are actually in some
cities it might differ because in some
cities there are just only four classes
but in some cities there are just five
like in grass for example Gdynia is next
neighbor of dance but there are only
four nevermind
we basically with this idea try to build
such a solution which might help to tell
you which trash pin you should use to
throw your trash basically and so I'm
passing this stage to my colleague and
he's going to talk about basically the
approach and afterwards we will I will
come back and try to show you to demo
some of the more so as we said already
we use transfer learning for for the
classification task and transfer
learning basically is very similar to
the human approach for learning things
so we use the data that we learned
before for categorizing new tasks so why
we actually use the transfer learning as
very simple like the calculation times
so using transfer learning the models
should predict like earlier the better
results so as you can see the curve we
should have higher start of accuracy
when it comes to a classification higher
slope and her asymptotes also the
probability of overfitting the model
might might be lower using the transfer
learning but be sure that you're using
the model that is related to our tasks
so like our problems should be basically
similar so for example let's maybe give
a bit detail here there are a lot of
state of our architectures like you know
it's the Alex net made the first huge
impact in the image nets competition so
then you know there was another call
state of the art architecture which is
16 came an inception arrest net ResNet
in different one so all of them the ours
you know
trained on different type of data set
and some of them are trained on you know
cats and dogs photos
of them are Bazin like very white of
different image glasses so basically
this is very important you should know
that have this state of the architecture
was trained and was built so you
shouldn't use the state of architecture
which is not related to your task
basically very convenient to use search
architectures so a couple of words about
the data set we used two different data
sets that are available on Google so
waste pictures and trash detection we
went through this all of those data sets
manually and selected the pictures that
the the quality of the pictures was
pretty nice say so basically we ended up
with four thousand of pictures we
divided it also manually to train and
test set and two different approaches to
classification problem so the first
approach was to classify like the set
the labels as we have in our trash bins
in Gdynia trash bins to be specific so
glass paper plastic and metal and the
other non cigar ash but we are aware
that for some classes especially plastic
we have a couple of different objects
that we can put there so for example the
milk box the plastic bottle and plastic
box let's say the structure of those
objects is very different so the model
might get confused when it comes to
classifying all of those three different
objects to one class that's why we also
wanted to try the model with eight
different labels so then we could merge
those labels into like one final plastic
one we should remember that there is
always a trade-off so with four labels
we have less labels so the model will
have like a smaller chance to to make
bad prediction so the accuracy should be
higher but in on the other hand using
eight labels
model performance might be better
because the model will understand the
structure of each object in a better way
yeah so those are the examples of
pictures that we used you can see there
are different of those yeah with with
uploading the data set to models we used
image data generator from cara's we're
scaling XI range zoom range and
horizontal flip to avoid too much over
fit of the model okay and the training
part basically all of the training was
conducted in Google collab we used
Google collab because they are providing
the free tpo
and it helped to develop model because
when we tried the same architecture on
CPU the approximation time of one epoch
was around two hours when you try it
with GPU it was around 40 minutes
something like that with TPO
we managed to shorten the time up to
like 52 seconds per epoch so this is
great but be aware that using TPU might
be confusing because when we trade the
same code the other day the time per one
epoch was around five minutes so somehow
it's not like 100% reliable but what we
actually came up with related to this
topic because this is you know free
platform and probably they are not
putting a lot of effort to manage this
resource when there is a like huge load
training the model and we were also
checking the time for example around
half past 5:00 p.m. the the TP was
getting confused and the process was
getting slower because in the United
States it was morning so probably like
there was a kind of problem with
resource management but still the good
resource because we didn't have to you
know have AWS or any other Google
competing engine to
form you know basically it was free
architecture as we said we used VG 16
with a couple of our additional layers
so two really good answers one soft
marks and two dropouts we are also early
stopping in learning phase we've rolled
back to the best performing one and we
compile it with atom optimizer and
categorical cross entropy laws so this
is how the architecture of VG's 16 looks
like we didn't try that VG 16 like
itself [ __ ] we tried to throws a
couple of layers of of these models so
we tried with frozen last for last eight
and last 12 layers of the model
so therefore like those layers were not
used in in the classification in bond
modeling part basically stands for flow
library for additional layers for
compiling we also in vgg 16 we used
initial weights from imagenet data set
may be small not here as you might know
that with tensorflow 2.0 you can also
call Kara's functions with internal flow
and it's a bit faster and it's it's a
bit you know
providing better performance that's why
we decided to go with tensor flow and
for some menial tasks we call Kara's
functions from the answer flow and it
was actually pretty pretty good so this
is how you basically create the model
it's so we can collect the VG 16 like
straight from tensor full models and
then for frozen 2 layers it's one very
simple loop so we can just set the layer
trainable to false and that's it
yeah we added the additional dances and
compile it and that's it so let's check
the results of the models so as we said
we tried two different approaches so
here you can see models that were
trained based on four classes so a
couple of similarities for initial
stages the test validation was accuracy
was much higher than the trained one for
some reason like 10 of our 15 iteration
it started to slow down and then we can
see like the small gap between train and
test accuracy we managed to reach the
point 86 point 85 accuracy for most of
the models for eight classes the initial
stages
went pretty similar so the validation
accuracy was higher initially but then
we we cannot see actually this gap
between the train and test at the latest
stages of the model but again the
accuracy is slower as we mentioned and
this is totally understandable
because we have basically more classes
so we can see how those labels were
actually predicted so both models
performed the best for trash so
non-circular bull wastes and both of
them were a bit confused when it comes
to the glass and plastic and metal
probably because of the structure of of
the bottles like plastic bottle and
glass bottles it's pretty much the same
so right now we will try to show you the
demo so basically just quick
introduction about queue up queue up is
an open source Python library and for
very quick development of applications
and you can basically develop
cross-platform applications you know it
can be desktop application can be
Android or Python sorry
iPhone iOS application so iOS
application so it's you can also go to
visit this website and you can you will
find very useful information here and
it's this framework okay probably you
cannot see on the screen right now but
okay so alright and this this framework
is also used for game development and
some gamers like what I mean game
developers are using it for this and
there are also some examples about I
think one of the PI data conferences
application was developed with this
queue up Kiwi framework so you can see
it's very very straightforward and very
easy to develop such you know very
simple applications as you can see here
just with a couple of lines you can have
very simple up and hours also looks
pretty pretty similar to this one I mean
not it doesn't say hello world of course
but you know it's not so complicated
application basically I will also try to
show you how this structure code
structure looks like
so basically basically you have my one
main PI file okay it's it's very hard to
control anyway so you have one main file
main PI file so basically here you are
giving the instructions to the to the
computer or to the app basically you're
saying that okay put here the button and
on this part it's happening put to the
put a button there and then take a photo
capture a photo save it to some location
and then afterwards you can clearly call
the peyten secret discreet where you
have this you know model prediction part
it's also very straightforward one
we are basically calling the calling the
model and here as you can see okay I am
trying okay
so basically here you can see we are
loading the model this is in the stored
in the h5 format so we are loading the
model and then passing the image here so
using this for using this image we are
generating the predictions those
predictions are provided as classes like
0 1 2 3 and then we are mapping them
here basically where we are having the
results so let's try to do like a quick
demo so maybe I would like I can show
you a couple of things which we actually
did today here we were sitting on the on
the rear side and we just you know was
testing the application so on the left
hand side or right I cannot say it's
right for you so you can see that you
know this is the batch and the model
predict is as a plastic and we also put
two glasses there and it also managed to
predict the glasses perfectly but we
have stored two
a problem when it comes to glass and
plastic and because those images are
pretty similar to each other so imagine
that bottle is also transparent and the
glass is also transparent so for example
yesterday we were also trying to testing
the model and application so when there
was a reflection on the plastic bottle
it's detected it as a glass which sort
of makes sense we are trying to add
additional features to deal with this
for example we are we are thinking about
adding reflection like collecting this
information from the image when we are
processing the image and passing it to
the model maybe it might help because
it's mainly based on the colors and do
those features because this VG structure
is extracting those features so
basically we are also trying to do some
ensamble learning perhaps maybe passing
this features to different model and
adding feeding the new features with the
second model and then merging them a
kind of having a he bridge structure but
yeah the there is a couple of things to
do here so here also on this chart you
can clearly see this the problem as you
can see we actually mainly have plastic
images so on the real reality they like
twenty eight of them aren't actually
really plastic they're glass so it
confuses the the plastic with glass
because of the things what I mentioned
also there are also bottles right so
think about those energy drink bottles
right they are colorful but think about
also wine bottle they're also you know
black or deaf in different colors so it
it a bit is getting confused alright so
let's try to run this up
I will try to make it a bit bigger okay
so basically of course for now we are
running this application from the common
prompt but it's easy to just run the
main PI file so it pops up me it pops up
a kind of window where you can take a
photo so for example we can take a photo
of the batch
can you please but without you okay we
lost the application it happens
okay yeah all the effort was just it was
just for this so but yeah of course this
is like I said it's very early alpha
version of this application but we
experienced many different things and it
was actually good experiment for us and
like you also mentioned I think Rafa was
mentioning that this very hard task so
we actually saw some points should be
improved and we will be working on this
and also we are planning to like I said
knock on the door of the municipality
and you know ask for some funding
companies supporting us and basically
converting it to a bigger project
because it might help you know to have
better segregation trash segregation
basically and it's also good experience
for us you know like we might have good
application perhaps if everything will
be alright but the first results are
promising so yeah I think we are pretty
much on the time
so thanks for your attention one two
questions nope okay have already spoken
to the municipality also what we heard
that in Ghana there's a very good try
segregation system and frame the place
where they can segregate the trash and
they are actually doing good job but
they would like to have it much better
and with less effort basically
and that's why they are asking people to
contribute so we are thinking that the
response will be positive and then maybe
we can have like a bigger project will
be good to have it in trash bins
actually some ideas like this so putting
some you know ibeacons to the trash bins
and it would understand your around this
trash bin and we are also thinking about
some loyalty points so let's say for
example if we call like 100 points you
would get free transportation ticket or
like lunch in some good place things
like that but of course it needs money
and it needs resources we have
everything in our mind and written
somewhere we will just you know put
everything together and just go and tell
them guys give us money please thank you
so much